microwave obama doesn't look like right
come back right
like a vision for a super clarity muscle
like my name is Gary Vee I've been
telling you I'm triple-a having a
pedigree the mean and a special my
specialty
I'm putting the work that I'm Jevon put
something a little bit different with
business depth Sunday I can actually air
them on Sundays so excited about that
I've got some good ones for you this
week and also pretty excited about about
what's been going on with the ones we've
been doing so excited here they come
facebook video very important part of my
world obviously put out a lot of stuff
on facebook.com slash Gary looking for
people who have big Facebook pages that
match the kind of content that I put out
that want to put out content on their
page bizdev Facebook you can see it
right here there's a forum just fill it
out you don't need to email the biz dev
email instep Sunday at vaynermedia
that's not this if you're a Facebook fan
page that is around motivation social
media business topics or just was
inspired by some of the stuff that I've
done and want to distribute some of my
videos looking for content distribution
partners fill out the form
leaving them notes what you want to
return but I'm looking for an army of 50
to 5,000 Facebook pages that we have a
kind of once in a month video that
I really think I just want the world to
see I want to have a team that wants to
natively distribute it through their
page there's a kind of new little tweak
on that that we've noticed some facebook
that we want to try to do and so if you
want to give back a little love or if
there's something you want to create
that kind of distribution for yours gary
beat.com slash of bizdev facebook link
right here obviously you're watching it
a lot for me to be in touch
getting serious about YouTube very
serious really looking to explode daily
be through the [ __ ] roof so YouTube
collaborations obviously I've been
saying no to most podcasts rogen I did
but saying you know if you've got a big
youtube page call it 500 thousands subs
or higher please email me below if you
want to do collaboration come to New
York or if I'm in your area do a couple
when I'm in Salt Lake City shonduras
looking forward to a brother
500 thousand subs or more on your
YouTube page and there's some
interesting way for us to collaborate
for me to incorporate let me know email
me below looking forward to it so a lot
of you know that I bought pure Wow
pure wild calm one of the leading female
media websites also notice on Instagram
a lot of 26 to 55 year old females doing
incredibly interesting stuff with their
Instagram account would love to
collaborate put in the title pure Wow
by the way in the last one putting the
title five hundred thousand plus YouTube
when you email these we need to separate
them so please use it in the title just
put pure Wow
collaboration looking for podcasters
bloggers and definitely Instagram and
YouTube influencers that are really
attacking that 25 to 45 year old female
demo see if we can do some really cool
stuff with the pure well team together
on some fun collaborations so check it
out also if you're into that kind of
content sign up for the newsletter pure
wild calm
bukka's all right this is the alternate
one I'm excited about this one
it's the ultimate business Sunday pitch
take a picture and post it up Instagram
or make a one-minute video and post on
Instagram use the hashtag bizdev sunday
the way I do it be Isay and tell me the
diss depth that you want to do pitch me
we're gonna look at all of it every
picture no Instagram stories main post
either picture or one-minute video pitch
on the business deal you want to do with
me what do you want what do I get
and let's pick one random person on
Monday or Tuesday to do the deal with so
the ultimate business Sunday pitch pitch
me on the deal what's the trade you and
I are gonna make all right
hope you love bizdev Sunday as much as I
do love you guys have a great rest of
your weekend and I will see you tomorrow
[Music]